hello I'm contento bizarre am the
managing director of early adventures so
I'm learning Davos and who attended some
of the young global leaders program and
today the main program started and a
decision about the Middle East and what
I'd like to report is that you know the
view of zep of that basically the
panelist what they said has been
extremely frustrating we've been hearing
the same and the same issues being
discussed and been seeing the same
people talking about the same thing and
talking in terms of millions and
hundreds of millions of jobs that are
acquired hundreds of billions of dollars
that are invested by Middle Eastern
countries and they need to invest in
education and the need to invest in
enterpreneurship and the need to invest
in job creation but you've seen long
very very little practical steps so I
don't know what happens when these
people go to their offices I don't know
why it's not difficult to translate but
they're talking about into actionable
small steps by governments in the Middle
East it's just extremely frustrating you
can see countries and regions and
nations of much less natural resources
doing much more in terms of buildup of
the acknowledged economy in terms of
encouraging entrepreneurship in terms of
encouraging innovation up until now had
this task in the utter burn is to get
somebody seed stage funding so somebody
is starting starting a new business
wanting to get some seed stage funding
wanted to go and build up a you know go
and you basically get space in an
incubator finds it very tough let's get
something done about it and this is me
reporting from davos thank you hey